so during the covid pandemic you may
remember the Government tried to shut
down virtually every business in the
country except the ones that pay them
big campaign donations Planned
Parenthood liquor stores Amazon and
Google one of the organizations they
tried very hard to shut down was the UFC
the fastest growing sport in the United
States we just sat down with the man who
runs the UFC Dana White he's the
president in Las Vegas and he told us
why he held fights well he kept his
business going and his sport operating
despite the coveted shutdowns watch
media does nothing they they they never
built anything they don't nobody depends
on them for a paycheck uh uh but all
they do is sit back and criticize
um I'm going to kill people I care more
about money than I do human life I I
heard it all and and the New York Times
as you can imagine was was blasting me
daily
head long and fascinating interview with
Dana White if you don't know who Dana
White is probably the most influential
certainly the most influential man in
sports and a smart man we're going to
air the whole thing Monday right here
also working on a documentary on him and
the UFC for Tucker Carlson Originals
coming out this winter but again it's
worth watching Monday eight Eastern
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight